before we get started today we just want
to let you know that we've got just a
handful of concerts left at the handful
this year and it's the only ones we have
planned into the future at this point so
if you want to see us do musical comedy
oh yeah you come to Albuquerque New
Mexico on November 20th Phoenix Arizona
on the 21st Sacramento California the
22nd in Valley Center California on
November 23rd singing some songs we're
gonna make these real special shows
because we ain't gonna do it for a while
Rhett come on out live.com that's rhett
and Link live.com get your tickets there
don't just don't just google it and
click on the first place you see that's
right now on with the biscuit welcome to
ear biscuits I'm Rhett and I'm link this
week at the round table of dim lighting
we're discussing but this is your
brainchild how do you want to put this
well the the catchy way to talk about it
is are we out of touch but the way we're
going to discover just how out of touch
we might be if we are with ourselves is
with aliens with what with generations
oh are we losing our grip on the trend
on the currency of pop culture our kids
are Generation Z by the way can you look
up what officially Jacob can you look up
officially what years you were supposed
to be born into be Generation Z just to
verify that just so we come back to it I
can seem knowledgeable and is there a
what generation are we we actually we
are 41 42 year old old farts it's we're
right so a lot of people call us X Z
neol zai think is what some people call
us because we're basically right in
between Generation X and Millennials and
we're not really either one if you're
like 41 42 years old you're this I think
is zinnias or X in heels okay is there
Generation Y yeah you missed it man no
one cares about those those people we're
off to the Z's which which Jacob will
clarify if it's our
and that that's our children there is I
mean I like a rough range war between
1995 and 2015 right so all of our
children yeah you know wait here's the
thing I I just take pride in the fact
that in this town when I tell people
when it comes up that we have kids oh
you got kids and I'm like yeah I got a
16 year old and then it's like they're
just this face just drops yeah they
can't believe you know in this town so
I'm I'm just grateful that I got I've
got I got kids that old and I still feel
this young but the question is hutch
with it well the reason 19 year old a 14
year old and a 9 I'll get into what
we're going we're going to go through
some generation Z slang that was on a
list that's the way that the list was
created is very funny
and so ok I'll get into that when we get
into the conversation you're gonna test
I'm gonna run through it with you see if
you know this stuff it's pretty long I
don't how much we'll get through I'm
gonna tell you whether or not I knew
that stuff but the reason I thought
about doing this was because I don't
even remember where I was but I realized
that I was saying something and I was
like I think I sound old because I
specifically listened to the way my kids
talk and some of the lingo that they use
in fact lingo is probably an a word that
makes me sound old you know what I'm
saying like Leo what's that dad and I
realized that if I'm like excited about
something or if I'm trying to tell
somebody that I think something's great
I might say like that's awesome and then
I was like I don't think my kids would
ever say that something was awesome
anymore I don't hear them say that no
and so I don't use the word awesome and
so I just started realizing that like oh
yeah I do even though we are in this
medium that is still considered new
media and people look at us as like oh
yeah those young guys on the internet
we're not we're old and we've got kids
that are getting older and about to go
to college in just a couple of years and
we are definitely out of touch to some
degree today we're going to find out
just how out of touch we are hmm I'd
like to give an update on my my shower
window situation yeah it's quite a
situation though it has nothing to do
with being in touch unless you unless
you want to talk about me being in touch
with my neighbour can I talk about it
out of my shower window while I'm
showering can you talk about it and as
without having you haven't seen anything
any lingo can you talk about it as if
you're in generation Z perhaps bro wow
that's off to a rough start
I think perhaps as I've previous as I've
previous my peeps my shower is totally
lit because well it's actually it'd be
hard to light anything in there in terms
of like set anything on fire because
it's so wet in there right get me
waterproof like like it or Charlaine I
mean they're there it's a special light
there are lights in there there are
there two recessed lights above the
shower which I don't use because I have
a window which lets in all of my natural
light and so it is lit by the natural
glow of the environment I don't ever
take showers when it's dark very very
rarely I'll take them in the morning but
interesting enough there are exceptions
and my update is related to an
exceptional time that I took a shower
because I don't know if you if you
haven't been listening to all these you
know don't feel guilty I'll bring you up
to speed
I actually feel a little guilty you're
missing out on you should keep up on the
updates with the fact that Rhett told me
when I see my neighbor leaving for work
and I'm in the shower shampooing I got
to make eye contact and assert my
dominance I can't remember why and I
definitely was for the future it was for
when the world falls apart and you're
asserting yourself as a leader of your
community and especially because I can't
remember why I don't remember why I
actually tried it but I did and then
ever since then his car's gone when I
get in the shower and I my routines to
say so I think
my dominance led him to adjust his
routine to go to work earlier just so he
doesn't have to almost see me out of
corner of his eye staring at him when
I'm shampooing my hair now as I've
established the window is a widescreen
format window and it exposes me from the
collar bones up I think from his vantage
point when he's in his driveway backing
out and he and he looks forward he can
see me but I went over this past weekend
I went mountain biking me and Lincoln
went mountain biking I didn't ask him to
describe it but he might would he
wouldn't have said awesome and he
wouldn't have said lit you really gave
up on the whole generations do you think
pretty early in this and that's tough
too tough so then when I got back let's
see it was probably what was key it was
kind of late it was it was dinnertime it
was like 6:00 or 6:30 and I was like
well I need to take a shower you know
I'm pretty sweaty so I get in there and
I'm taking a shower and I'm still I got
my window open I'm looking out it's like
oh the sun's kind of going down this is
a beautiful time to take a shower and
enjoy my window and I looked at the
driveway and I saw my neighbor's car
there he was not in the car and then I
turned a little bit further and I looked
in a place that I had not looked and it
was my neighbor's house and how have you
not looked there well because I'm
looking out at the majestic scenery
there's like mountains and stuff I'm not
gonna look at his house now I do can I
just interject and say that you talked
about seeing the scenery while showering
as if the only time you see the scenery
around your house is while showering
like out of every other window it
doesn't exist or perhaps bro if you go
outside maybe you would also see it like
you talk about it like you're on a
spaceship that has like a holodeck
situation yeah and the only way our the
only beings what earth was like it one
time is to go take this shower the only
other place I can see the disadvantage
point of the mountains is if I walk out
my front
which is nice you know you're exiting
you get to see it but I don't have any
other windows like both boys have a
window in their bedroom that faces that
same direction but they're those are the
only four places you can see that
vantage point so and I'm in the shower
every day I got a look at something okay
and it's not gonna be my neighbor's
house but I happen to look over there
and they put in a new window they
remodeled after I put in my shower
window mhm and I look through that
window and I realized I'm looking at the
family next door eat dinner no yeah he
not seen the dinner table so far because
they haven't been out I've never been at
it so it's just like kind of a dark this
is a window to nothing so now I'm
freaking showering and I'm looking at
and he's at the head of the table
looking at me dinner
oh the tables like turn I'm like man you
I feel like a heel he was slow playing
you he mayn't he lulled you into
thinking that your dominance had worked
he was like I'm gonna leave early a
couple of times but I'm just waiting for
that day he accidentally takes a shower
while we're eating dinner and I'm gonna
stare him down and a man looking at you
while he's eating is especially dominant
yeah I wasn't eating because in like the
history of the hand the history of the
animal kingdom while you're eating like
this is it this is when you show who's
boss and if you can eat and look at
somebody in the eye
you own them he owns you cuz eating is
survival it's like I'm currently taking
in the calories I need to dominate you
are you eating right now
no you're just getting clean like what
who needs to be clean yeah right this
way he's oh my gosh I think you're right
cuz you know what what was the
expression honest that was that was two
days ago
and then this morning I'm taking a
shower at my normal allotted morning
time and I like in the car I look out to
it and yeah he did I swear to you he was
in his car this guy he must be listening
to the potty
[Laughter]
I are we on our time looking at it I
really tried it's like man yep I think
this is your dominance you're
controlling me man I'm sitting here
staring at a guy eating dinner well
let's say I'm having a lot of fun it's
wrong I've never seen this man it's like
sure you know bad but shower nobody
wants to watch in dudes shower while
they're eating dinner I did I didn't see
him in his wife kids we got the other
day when I was dropping Shepard off at
your house they were getting in the car
and I I was like oh I get to see this
guy yeah but he got in a car right as I
realize I got a good look at his wife I
mean I didn't like make it dot it and
try to dominate her with my looks or
anything but I didn't get I didn't get a
good look at it and every time I talk
about this Christi and Lily just tell me
dad you got to stop talking about this I
mean I think you mean all this I mean I
just can't help but give you an update
because it is this all in my mind and
are you are you planting these things in
my mind because Chrissy's like you
didn't really look at him out the window
you're just saying that for the podcast
I'm like no I did I did I do that you
know the real thing it's my sis of
realities we blurred by you and the
shower window listen you're gonna thank
me later for what when you've got that
guy when you've got a dog collar on that
guy and you've got a chain around his
neck I'm convinced the big one happens
you'll think me I don't if he's there
tomorrow morning man
and what if he's eating well I mean it
takes a little time between us recording
the release in the episode then him
listening to it and then him deciding to
take a turkey leg into his car as he's
going to work and dominate me
by eating like a car if that happens if
he eats if he makes a nice car while
eating in the car he's definitely
listening now because you talked about
your neighbor like a year ago and the
whole thing about like the tree and
stuff and no completely reconciled the
whole thing and I were I wouldn't say
we're friends at this point but we're in
we're in regular communication about if
somebody's gonna have a loud party or
whatever my wife is also in
communication with your neighbor yeah my
neighbors yeah she knows her now she met
her around town no yeah how does she
know how is the they workout at the gym
together how does she know they see each
other around town huh how did it come to
get how did it come out
I don't know how Christy put it together
but she did yeah well it doesn't matter
what good friends we exchanged wine at
Christmas time okay I mean that's it
that's it that's it that's a sign of a
good neighbor
maybe if I if I get in the shower with
food next time then I can still assert
my dominance and I do think it should be
a large turkey he's got to be like meat
on a bone tiny life is the one time
where a turkey leg makes all sense
because like a tomahawk cut I could
build her like a large beef or a beef
rib that could be good could be that
yeah but it's hard to come by though
turkey legs dime-a-dozen and you don't
want to do like a corn dog cuz that'll
disintegrate in the shower I'm gonna
have to keep it yeah I meant because
you're right I'm gonna have to keep that
slab of meat in the shower until the
right opportunity and I'm have to pick
it up meeting it's gonna have to be
there I mean we I think you know what
you got to do yeah I I feel good about
this I think I think this is the right
decision okay well I continue I look
forward to seeing how it goes you really
got to come up to my shower
yeah I'm really interested when we get
it tomorrow before I get a turkey leg in
there I'll come up there a nice steamy
turkey leg okay we're gonna see just how
out of touch we are but first we want to
let you know what are we telling people
about this time the leek create Creek
Marsh is just it's been out a week so
you can know it hasn't been out of he
drops when you're hearing this right
this is the video about water I know
this is confusing but
it only lives in the video version
that's right see I got a sharp mind it's
been out a week it's been out a week so
this pig picking shirt is is an
authentic replica of one that you might
get at a pig pickin but this is related
to the book and we've got a hyper color
shirt that changes color
temperature-sensitive just like the one
referenced in the book this is bleak
recon it
we got the lost causes shirt we got a
Buies Creek school a bleak Creek School
sweatshirt
it says bleak Creek demons on it what
does we get uh all types of check it out
mythical dot-com and also there's a book
that all the merch comes from called the
lost causes of bleak Creek and buy it
for a friend if you already have one or
if you don't have one why haven't you
bought one yet come on read y'all you
know the more you know of our Burton and
Reading Rainbow and things alright thank
you for supporting entertainment reppin
your boys okay so there was an article
and you know what before we you know I
didn't want to mention I wanted to
acknowledge everyone who's talking about
lost causes of Lee Creek right all the
mythical society is a great conversation
is happening there we're really enjoying
hearing how you are processing the story
and in experience in it it's it's um
it's a it's a big part of our
satisfaction like it it's it feels like
a completion to hear from you guys in
terms of I haven't worked so hard on
this novel so on Twitter hashtag bleak
Creek at the mythical society and
wherever you want to discuss the novel
we and we're gonna appreciate we're
gonna enter into that discussion so make
sure you are tagging all those things so
we can see them as we begin to gather
questions and comments and insights and
observations that you have made about
the book and then we're gonna do a
podcast sometime soon where we enter
into that conversation and maybe offer
some insights into that so you're gonna
what what is it what is this oh there's
Liz there's a guy we'll see where he is
where is he he is in where yeah
where's here he's in Lowell
Massachusetts okay
his name is mr. Callahan he's a teacher
and he there was an article at least in
BuzzFeed I think it may have been in
other places as well earlier this year
where he started to keep a list of the
words that he heard his students using
because he was like I'm lost I don't
understand what this stuff means but
every time I hear them use a certain
phrase or a word that I don't understand
that seems like there's a generational
divide here I'm going to write it down
and then get them to define it for me
okay cool and how old is he I don't know
specifically but I thought you told me
he was about RA Oh UCF 43 43 is this the
article is like 43 year old teacher yeah
okay so he's our age which makes us even
more relevant to us and he's our
irrelevance more dealing regularly with
generations II people which we do
because we our parents to them and also
I know there's a fair amount of people
would born between 95 and 2015 who
listen to this podcast and enjoy the
other things that we do so he started
making this list and of course when word
got out about the fact that he had this
list he made it into a Google Doc that
is now publicly available to anyone who
wants to open source it and I think the
interesting thing about this as opposed
to simply entering in these phrases into
the urban dictionary and getting the
definition which I could have done I
wanted to just stick with mr. Callahan's
list exclusively because I think that
maybe some of his definitions or the
definitions that he got from his
particular students in Massachusetts
some people may who know you may have a
contention with one of these definitions
I don't know but this is this is the
information that he received
you're gonna definitely know some of
these and you're definitely not hit me
with one so a force just starting with
the first one two words a a four space
force yeah like a force to be reckoned
with like that
the complimentary it's a way to describe
someone like my neighbor is who showers
while staring at me is such a force it's
like it's well that's that that's your
old man's understanding of it which is
what I would agree with but it is
unnecessarily excessive effort okay yeah
that man who stares me while showering
is a-ok that's even better I'm more
accurate and I don't even unnecessarily
extol read it because you're gonna read
other things unnecessarily excessive
effort I don't even know how that would
be used in a sentence he's forcing it
that's a force yeah yeah that was a
force and now you're forcing him you're
trying too hard
but it's it now I force we used to use
this my dad would say like in its in
sports language like sometimes you'll be
you'll be shooting and you're trying too
hard like shooting the basketball you
realize don't force it don't force it
don't force it let it come to shoot it
just let it happen
just relax into it so is that the same
thing I think so yeah but it's of course
they use it in a specific way they
there's not saying don't force it
they're saying a force that's a force so
there's no there's no no usage in the
sentence I wanted Callahan needs a new
column yeah mr. Callahan we would invite
you to update your Google Doc but I mean
he needs to open it up for edits he
needs to open source it bang thirty's
never heard this bang 30s I'm about to
go bang 30s that means like I'm gonna
mm-hmm I'm gonna take a power nap I'm
gonna sleep for 30 minutes I'm a bang
out 30 yeah that's not what it means
power now I was taking for 30 minutes I
think that's too long is it yeah it
should be 20 huh the generation Izzy
they don't they're they're taking too
much to fight someone as in a physical
altercation so you've got my fists plus
my fists is 10 plus your fists
your fist is 20 plus when three people
fight no I think it's my fist in my fist
your fist in your fist and then either
both of my feet both of your feet or one
of your foots but none of my head one of
my feet either both you feeding on a
mine or whatever so it's a it's a but
it's a boxing match we're kicking with
one leg is allowed but you don't know
where the thirty comes from I have no
idea they're banging 30s in the in the
common area we got to call the Popo we
got a banging 20s would have made so
much more sense banging twenties and
thirties again we have no du général
hands not given us you know I mean do
you want if you I didn't I just thought
that we should just let our ignorance be
on display and that might be more
entertaining then I'm just trying to
clarify some of its it doesn't seem like
we're ignorant it also seems like we're
crotchety old men because we're
complaining about why it doesn't make
sense even though we've been told what
it means well I mean we may another we
can have opinions beat your face beat
your face yeah beat your face beat your
face
I'm getting frustrated that there's no
sentence because I don't know is this a
is this is this an imperative like hey
man please my wife I thought my wife was
ready but then I realized she was still
beating her face putting on makeup yeah
okay applying makeup beat your face also
cake your face bake your faces too easy
beat your face as I bet this came from
the one of those people who make those
YouTube videos about makeup called
makeup people no makeup gurus yeah
beauty guru the euros you use beauty
gear easy Keeley's I bet it came from I
bet one of them said beat your face cuz
here's the thing that's almost my kids
have not said any of these they my kids
don't sale it they don't even say dope
like to me the one that if I was going
to make a calculated F
to try to speak gen Z I'd say dope but I
cannot bring myself to do it I've got
too much pride and I know that I just I
don't mean that's kind of old school
though but it also they also say it they
say they all say it right if something
is good if something's cool or awesome
they say that's dope man dope and dopes
Brown does your kid none of your kids
say that my kids do not say that I think
Locke says it sometimes all right lock
skylock as I said any of these but Locke
definitely because he's in the hip-hop
he's I've heard a number of them is
maybe Lincoln has said it
maybe Lincoln has said it because it's
definitely that hip-hop pop culture
influence there but I just could you
ever hear yourself saying that's dope
dope I actually out of all the things on
this list the dope is feels like
low-hanging fruit I know I know that's
why I'm asking it's dope man
I Lee would you say how could you say
I'm gonna say it today you're gonna try
it out I'm gonna try it out I don't even
think that's one though is it I mean
it's not on this list
it just feels although obvious but I do
agree they say it now here's the thing
well let's go all the way we have to
agree that we're cool with each other
saying dope because if we're not you
know what's gonna happen well you can't
you can't if I say it and you're around
you can't look at me like right you just
dropped it right and you do that you
can't do that to me because that's what
we do we we have this like we we're very
self-aware and I don't know we have this
and maybe it's a gift maybe it's a curse
but we definitely have this constant
critic of ourselves that's like how
would other people be proud I be
perceiving someone else if they were
doing or saying what I'm doing right now
that's self-awareness by my definition
and then we have the second layer
because we're together so much that we
police each other so we're we're other
aware so if if either of us does
anything that's out of the ordinary
a little
especially when it comes to like saying
something like dope is a perfect example
we'd be all over that for the other one
be like really this ain't that ain't you
you're fronting I don't think I would
say that if you said something was dope
I'll be like oh that's an entry now if
you said sincerely no if I said it
sincerely there I would know that
something in your brain had been
triggered that was like he's trying
something it's like when I got those
pants and I roll in with my pants and
you're like your pants are what are
those like hammer paint I don't care
what you said they were like they're
like baggy pants baggy jeans I don't
know if I said anything you didn't have
to say anything because I knew what you
were thinking because again it's this
self policing thing you thought
something you noticed the pants you
decided not to see me there was a big
there was a big difference from your
pants that you've been wearing and all
of a sudden your pants very different
yeah right so so it's like what you
needed what I needed from you man was
permission I needed you to say
permission from me I acknowledge your
pants and you know what I don't know if
I like him yet but I'm applaud you
expanding yourself like literally the
pants are expanded you know if you said
something like that be like it's kind of
like when we devoted an entire hour to
talking about your hair growing out it's
a little different that's not good hands
I can't take it off but you but in the
in this in the policing way I stepped
out of the way like you said your piece
and I stepped out of the way into like
you knew that there was not gonna be any
criticism for me or constant judgment
like cutting my eyes like okay what is
he doing I don't agree with this or I
think this is suspicious or this thing
this didn't really him you know can we
do that with the word dope I'm gonna say
it today and we're going to two
different places today together and I
can think I believe that and both so I
will use it in both circumstances I'll
say dope and maybe something else that
we we learn about I have heard this well
I think when I do it I'm gonna do it too
can we both do no you need a different
word
it was my idea okay within you're gonna
have dope I'm gonna do a different word
I don't we can't go into a place where
we're with somebody and then both you
were like rhett and Link both describe
different things as dope see you're so
self-aware man yeah that's what they
think I mean I I I don't really care but
I do in an experiment it needs to be in
with the weak we got to set all the
parameters it's like one person says
dope see how it feels - people say dope
something's in the water
[Music]
[Laughter]
man I'm I'm nervous about I don't want
people to be like right you know I'm
getting fools reading about saying dope
do you know you know what rhett and Link
say when they like something they say
it's dope
I heard them both described this thing
is dope
oh comes in 30 minutes of each other cuz
awesome is tired big tired and I just
made that up like I put big in front of
something I see that didn't work yeah
what okay you gotta choose another word
well I'm let me guess let me get to some
I heard I was hoping I've heard this one
bops bops now I know there's a debate on
called Bob and he's talking about like
he's looking for a Bob like he's looking
for he wants his song he wants his track
to bop to him it means it means
something in terms of like to feel he
gets like it makes you kind of makes you
move in a certain way that then you got
a you got to do that certain rhyme
scheme that they do now I think your
rappers I think you might be
overthinking it I think it just means
it's like a it's a good it's a good song
like a enjoyable song he says a modern
enjoyable song oh okay now I knew this
one no you know I think he can be using
a couple of ways because I got out to
the baby he's definitely you Carolina
I've heard blocks say that something
bops
that bops that's because yeah that's
very hip-hop that that bops or I guess
you could say that's a Bop I don't think
you can say that's up yeah you can I
think he can
that song that bops though I think is
better
it's anymore that's like more refined
it's like a like they wouldn't say I'm
looking for a banger you're looking for
a bop now you don't want a banker
anymore bangers are over whereas we
would bangers aren't dope we would have
just a good hook yeah it's old old
school well that a hook applies to a
certain part of the song no that's a hit
ooh that's a hit that's what I couldn't
say I think you'd say another one that's
popping that's what you would say it's
pop pop it might be on here a Bop is
poppin old I mean this is not a
comprehensive list
now this one's yeah he's got bouta in
there about a-- like bouta bouta like no
Bo UTA like i'm about to bow to mmm yeah
I don't know if I should I think you
should take that off the list mr.
Callahan because I'm about up I'm bout
up dance 30s what was it pop 30s bang 30
bang 30s I'm bada bang 30s
if you don't play my bop now I've heard
there's two different versions of this
I'm catch a fade catch a fade what's the
other version catch these hands catch
these hands haven't heard that either
oh I've heard that my son this is
fighting - yeah whatever like sometimes
you've got to catch about it catch the
athenian lines will like do some like
shadow box and slap box and cut inside
stuff and like you know and like i'll
just see him in the kitchen i go out to
him and hit him that's what we do in the
McLaughlin family I mean you play fight
and you start you're gonna catch these
hands dad I haven't he I've never called
the hands but catch this fade catch a
fade is also feel like I feel like a
news anchor they fade it's also
acceptable
I thought fade was a haircut the maid
was I think it's if you like punch
someone on the side of the head where
laughs a glancing blow of the head yeah
if you give them a glancing blow to the
to the temple technically if you punch
them in the temple that's where the fade
is technically if you catch a fade you
would actually grab hold of the hair see
now you're going to fight in two literal
you catch it with your face but isn't it
you beat your face but the idea of
action a cop literally catching
someone's hands who's trying to fight
you that's awesome like if I was like
describing a fight a high-school fight
and I was like dude this dude totally
caught his hands oh yeah he literally he
tried to punch him and he caught his
hand yes yeah punch me in the face right
now see that that's like superhero stuff
yeah man yeah punch me with the other
yeah see that
I think he's and now I'm gonna bang your
hands together and make up 30 times make
up yeah I'm like a firework you have to
do it three times to get to 30 cuz it's
ten fingers my um my dad would visit me
in college and leading up to Christmas
time or maybe it was my birthday I'm
pretty sure it's Christmas time cuz I
remember buying winter clothes because
he would take me to the mall and we
would just we'd go on like a shopping
spree we did this like for two or three
years in a row in college and I remember
what you said about how you and Locke
would like give love licks to each other
like punch each other I remember I was
walking in the Crabtree mall with my dad
and we were shopping one Christmas and
like I was buying buying stuff in the
90s and I was probably seeing stuff he
didn't understand yeah I don't
awesome as a sidenote I don't remember
that we were like heavy into the like
vernacular like I do think a lot of it
comes from hip-hop culture like there's
there's so many sayings and then there's
the internet culture and there's so many
so many personalities like not just
beauty gurus but everybody on the
Internet has a way of like coming up
with their phraseology and then it kind
of Mima fine and I won't even get into
memes yet but I don't recall as a
sidenote when I think back to walking
down
all with my dad that I was like that we
were seeing those type of things I mean
we listen to rap music but we also knew
that it wasn't for us to speak in the
same way it was like we were you know it
wasn't it wasn't the most part it wasn't
popularized culture in the way that
hip-hop is now so I think we caught we
called things cool something's cool
something is awesome we didn't use rad
actually never did rad which that's come
back in like a hips book that's the
hipster terminal when I was in
California like from a just three to
five I specifically remember people
saying rad because that was like early
eighties what there was a surf culture
and skate culture also was a place that
had a lot of terminology they used the
word tubular it's yeah and gnarly yep
and so a lot of those things so you have
these subcultures Feldman remembers
tubular yes you say did you say tubular
did you ever use that seriously totally
dude
but I was walking down there and I
remember we were gonna buy some some
some big baggy jeans or something and I
just reached over and I just I punched
my dad in the shoulder just like a love
lick you know he we didn't have that
thing that you in law had with you like
shadowboxing or whatever but like just
as a show of affection I did I we were
in conversation I can't remember the
specific context but I punched him in
the shoulder and that was the end of it
and then it was um like a year later oh
yeah my dad is talking about his
shoulder he's like yeah I'm I'm still
having some trouble with my shoulder I'm
like what do you mean because I actually
have some trouble my shoulder I think
it's like this might be a genetic thing
like my shoulder pops out of joint he's
like well mine started when you punched
me that day in the mall I actually had
to go to the doctor and he said that
like a ligament was separated man I
separated a ligament on my dad trying to
give him a lovely I've said this for
years you this is why don't wait any
time we have to do something we're like
it requires you hitting me are you doing
something you don't
know your own strength or you don't or
you try to do it a little bit harder I I
you hit him too hard man well obviously
and I felt horrible about it I mean
you've never permanently injured I
wasn't trying to prove anything
it was obviously no I'm just saying it's
like you just did you did it it was
excessive
so I tell Lincoln like Lincoln will
start to rough house me and I'm like
very especially because I actually do
have shoulder issues and I'm doing like
physical therapy for my shoulder because
I'm hype i have hypermobility that's
what I'm diagnosed with like my all my
joints my shoulder joints and elbow
joints are like they're a little too
mobile and they're not supported enough
so we'll start roughhousing
because I'll grab him and like put him
in a bear hug or something and I I'm
very aware the combination of my what I
did to my dad and then how my shoulder
feels it like he's gonna do the same
thing to mean it's gonna be a legacy
that would not be lit or dope I will
never say lit that like dope I think I
can do something about the way your
mouth is shaped well and you can say it
kind under your breath like dope but
like lit it's like it's lit you gotta
say it like Travis Scott or sometimes I
say lady I've heard like say Liddy which
is the alteration of lit you know this
one clap back that's easy that's when
you retort you you give back what they
gave to ya you get an insult you respond
with the equal or greater in Seoul but
clapped clapped now I mean back in 90s
hip-hop culture the flat the clap was uh
was an STD STI we'll call it
don't call him a disease anymore he
caught an infection infection yeah an
STI all right formerly known as an STD
why do they have to change that I don't
know just so it's more approachable I
don't is it always an infection I think
so yeah it's just sometimes it's a
disease
I think they're because the disease is
not something that can be is it is
necessarily transmitted that could be
something that is just I don't think
that's the reason I think it might be
because because it could be a genetic
disease like something an infection
implies that like I guess you can take
penicillin and cure it you can get rid
of it but the selection can be passed
and some in a disease doesn't
necessarily have to be a communicable
disease it can be in communicable
disease or it could be a genetic disease
and so you can't give somebody a
sexually transmitted genetic disease
unless they're your offspring and at
that point it's get the trigger it all
breaks down like if you have a weird
penis like I'm saying if you have it
like I'm saying an STD it's not weird
guy had a weird pain I'm saying if you
got something genetically wrong with
your penis that would be considered a
disease and then you have it you pass it
you pass a weird penis and drum onto
your child okay that's that would be
that is it that could be a that's
technically a sexually transmitted
disease because no it's not genetic oh
no you have sex - Kevin oh you're wrong
you're wrong in so many administrative
I'm demonstrating why they don't use STD
anymore that's what cuz it's STI I'm
sorry I brought it up because we neither
one of us know I have herpes do you have
the kind of mouth do you have the class
I don't know I don't know what the
syphilis I don't know what is the clap
somebody I don't know because somebody
look that up somebody clap back on the
come on
everyone is afraid to Google the clap on
the work on the work Wi-Fi gonorrhea
gonorrhea now they've got super
gonorrhea you heard about this this is
okay
it's my new video we don't know how to
speak to the children but we have so
much information that they need my new
favorite superheroes
for gonorrhea super gonorrhea is
basically a lot of infections are
turning a lot of viral infections are
becoming impossible to treat or
bacterial both basically completely
immune to treatment and so if you get
the strain of gonorrhea that they can't
treat anymore you got super gonorrhea
and I just think it never goes away
unless you've got weird penis central
which at that point it counteracts it
and yeah you so you don't want you don't
want gonorrhea and you definitely don't
want super gonorrhea and ironically the
people who need to communicate these
things the most need to be able to speak
the language of Gen Z so you're saying
that like if we make a brochure like
what your mother would have had at the
health department yeah that's all about
STI is it needs to say things like got
the clap will clap clap back clap back
on the clap clap back on the clap with a
condom too late too late
clap back on the clap with get ahead of
the clap penicillin okay yeah I don't
know if it's the only word anymore
clapped means a crazy person which even
that I don't think gins even says use
the term crazy anymore no yeah that's
it's that's not PC you can't call
somebody crazy nope but or someone who
was punched hey I don't know these
people up in Massachusetts I don't know
if this is a representative of all of
Gen Z mr. Callaghan there's a lot of
reference to fighting man he got clap
cuz he caught him hands cracky
crikey crash crikey crikey crikey that
should be on the list cracky cracky
that's when you when you're like when
you laugh a lot
man fall they were that simple man Don
is so cracky you can't hold it together
it's someone who Jules vapes hope it's a
vapor so it's it's like it's like you're
you have an addictive habit an addictive
man and these these kids man
they're vaping like crazy man like Locke
said that basically any time you go in
the bathroom at their school where all
our kids go now
yeah my kid I encourage my kids to use
the restroom frequently they cuz I
encourage them to be hydrated now that
might be working against me because now
they it's valve a well they're doing in
volunteer getting secondhand vapes man
because the kids are vaping in there and
I don't know why I don't understand why
they can't kids are vaping like in class
I think they have crack down on it
cracky
speaking of cracking I think they've
cracked down a little bit what there's a
stories of people's people die I mean
with the people dying and they were
trying to get to the bottom as of this
recording they're still trying to get to
the bottom of what's what's killing
these all you think do you think
sometime between the recording of this
and the publishing they're gonna solve
it you're a very hopeful breaking news
every day I mean there's like black
market vapes being created but they
haven't definitively said that that's
what it's associated with but all vaping
is most likely bad for you you know and
not just the nicotine which kids
shouldn't have but which we talked about
with when we had the Surgeon General on
him we had the Surgeon General on
remember that and we did a mythical
morning vaping thing yeah a lot of good
that did and it was funny because there
was a couple of like there's these
vaping YouTube channels and there was a
couple people that came after us and
they were like look don't know what
they're talking about vaping is
completely safe they're speaking out of
ignorance listen whatever they find
write whatever they find I know that
some of the people who are dying are
probably getting like black market stuff
this guy other chemicals are in it or
whatever but the bottom line is your
lungs remain to breathe air right yeah
and so changing the concentration that
drastically of whatever it is you're
putting into your body even if it isn't
combusting at the same temperature that
tobacco would be combusting at it it
can't be good big this is not a good
thing and if you're cracky meaning
you're on that thing all the time
nicotine is highly addictive well and
the reason and then your your your your
your adjusting this vapor all this how
much more you end up doing so much more
than you typically would with smoking
because at least we were coming up if
you wanted to smoke you had to go to the
sea had a smoking pit it harness central
high school there was a smoking pit I'm
sure they don't have this anymore
but basically there was that depressed
literally depressed and also physically
depressed area that people stood out
there and smoked and but you had to go
out there to do it so how many
cigarettes are you gonna get to smoke in
a day right yeah but with this vape you
can just they're doing it in class crack
is everywhere man hmm don't be a crack
II find a new hobby we're not even out
of the seas get cherry pick a little bit
because I also want to talk about the
dynamic of I think our like us having
children at the age they are now is a
dynamic that I'd like to explore finesse
I've heard this one is this a noun or a
verb this is a verb well if you finesse
something or someone you like you you
take a light touch to get what you want
I can't think that it means exactly that
there it means to steal Oh to steal I'm
gonna finesse your mug it's kind of like
you got sticky fingers but a light light
you can stick your hand on somebody's
pocket and pull out a wallet and they
won't know it cuz you're you're very
finesse finesse is also a hairspray it
is here no okay of course everyone knows
low key and there is a high key Thor and
Loki my kids use low key and hike and
high key so it's like I Loki a menace
father I didn't want to have that's a
qualifying low key it's like it could be
on the down yeah you have heard for this
from your children they don't say it
don't say low key like low key is
probably the most common one that I've
heard
amongst on this list I've also heard
this one likes is this all the time
fax fax now to me that's memespeak and I
think that I I don't know what I don't
know how I know but I can just tell when
my kids go into memespeak Lily does this
a lot I mean she she created a Pinterest
account just to save memes that she can
go back to and laugh at like they
snicker to herself on her phone whenever
you needed better were than when she's
you know so you can crack e up with
herself no she's not I look for one that
is what you do with memes but she engine
she'll say it and it won't be this like
yeet but it'll I can just tell she goes
into this beep that oh you just quoted a
meme did you not and she's like yeah I'm
like and I used to be like what could
show it to me you know cuz it conjures
up this visual why are you saying that
about facts though because I think that
facts is memespeak like there's people
will write some it'll be it there'll be
a statement and then it'll just say
facts and you say facts when it's like
somebody says something that you
strongly agree with I think that's what
it means
yeah that's definitely what it means but
I mean I'm sure it could be in a meme
but like it's also just linked it's just
a slang like somebody says something
like facts but you see it in meme form a
lot I'm good and I don't know which came
first but I know there's lots of things
that that my kids say that are they just
quoting memes to each other conjuring a
visual image that's a shared experience
and that makes the other person laugh
it's like an inside joke and I mean my
opinion I'm just like eat it eat it do
you know where yeet came from some kid
who threw something and when he threw it
he said yeet and then that's where it
came from
so it was just a little video that
people passed around with this kid
saying eat and then he started to mean
throwing something yeah
special that's special man I like that
that's the Internet
oh okay there's a couple okay there's a
few here that are very old-school and I
guess they're coming back at least
they're coming back in Massachusetts in
mr. Callahan's class get hip means to
adopt a new trend which is what it meant
for us
jams okay an old enjoyable song but
that's my jam okay yeah I'm dead it's
like I I think that I think we elicits
that response a lot I see that in
response to the things that we've done
in our show it's like it it it it shook
you in a positive way it was amusing
yeah I'm dead shook you in a positive
way I'm shook shook could be like moved
in a negative way yeah I'm shook I don't
know what to say man real one real one
yeah that's referring to a person who's
authentic you're like a valid person
somebody you trust it's a real one no
cap no cap no cap man you're using an
accent am I using an accident using a
generation see like slightly informed by
it okay like you're a guy listen to
hip-hop sometimes like your eyebrows
have to kind of like know what man your
eyebrows kinda have to go together a
little hat no cap that's right I mean
it's really when you do your eyebrows
like that you start to seem like you're
saying something that's a little more
cool no cap means no limit I can't be I
can't be contained no too literal it
means I'm serious no lie for real this
one's interesting period t is period
with a T on the end I don't know if that
is a typo by mr. Calvin dot and a T just
period a word period and then T on the
end of it as if its period period period
what if I'm sure that's every day
it says Ceefax
now it doesn't remind me of Justice
which is that do you know about these
visco girls oh I know he sounds so oh
you mean the ones with the cameras
no it's girls again I think Lincoln
knows a Lincoln he said he wanted to be
this for how he said I want to be a
visco girl for Halloween I'm like but
I've heard a little bit but tell me
about that and he was like you have a
you have a Hydra flask you have a lot of
scrunchies in your hair and maybe on
your arms you like have a hat or a shirt
that says like save the turtles and
you're wearing yoga pants you weren't
like Lululemon right but where was it
where does the visco come from I don't
know VSC oh I thought that I think well
I thought it has something to do with a
camera and I'm like so are you kind of
talking like like a girl coming who
seems like she's coming from the gym but
she never went to the gym but she likes
environmental causes and she has like a
high ponytail like ariana grande and
he's like yeah what is it
generally uses an insult for young
colleges go but that's what they look
like right it's a type of person who
uses that ass I can imagine that he
decided to be an e boy which I was like
it what is that emo and he was like was
it yeah he's like you know you wear like
this way wear like a chain you wear like
a you know for Halloween and he you wear
like a long you were like black and
white clothes and like you part your
hair down the middle cuz I was like I
got a pizza costume you who wears like a
I want to look I want to look cool for
Halloween go being a boy then but you'll
slay Oh slay is one what what do you
think I mean what we're obviously really
showing our dad I don't think this and I
is it
are we actually more in touch with the
fact that we're or are we more let me
ask that again are we
we think over you more in touch that
were out of touch because of the age of
our kids what's the dynamic there well I
feel like I think what you talked about
earlier in this sort of self-regulating
tendency that we have both the regular
cells in to regulate one another
it makes adopting like a new a new word
into your let into your terminology it
makes it it it makes us really hesitant
to do that right and so because it's
like what does that say about me if I'm
suddenly using this new word and so we
haven't picked up on a lot of new thing
we haven't changed the way that we've
talked in terms of the terminology a lot
over time but what we have done is is
illustrated by your big pants is we've
kind of in ways that maybe people that
we went to high school with that are
didn't choose to be youtubers for a
living don't necessarily follow the
trends now one of the things we we
talked about fashion before so we we
were gonna do a podcast about that but
we're not but one of the things I was
talking about with Jessi I was like I
don't
something about now that I've got kids
who like I've got a teenager in my house
and if I were to just say I'm gonna go
to Urban Outfitters and I'm just gonna
buy everything on the rack at Urban
Outfitters and dress that way now I'm
dressing the same way as my 15 year old
kid and at some point it kind of feels
like I don't want to do that anymore
and I and I and I told Jessi I was like
is it because lock is now a teenager and
we're going into the same store and
we're looking at the same clothes and
for the first time ever I'm just going
into a place like Urban Outfitters and
just thinking I don't know what there's
anything in here for me
mm-hmm and she said well could be part
of it but I also think that you've
gotten to an age where you kind of know
what looks good on you you kind of know
what shapes look good on you and you may
not like the shapes like Shia LaBeouf
said on that one and that brought us
back interview our favorite hot ones
episode ever of Shia LaBeouf talking
about how the way he sees closes he just
thinks about shapes he doesn't think
about colors or patterns he thinks about
shapes and I was like I've never
connected more with something I think
about shapes and it probably has
something to do with just being him a
big man but anyway I found myself
resistant like you know and you've
always been a little bit more like if
there's somethin trend that's gonna
happen like you're gonna you're gonna
open that door earlier than I am and
I've got reasons I won't go into that
are boring about why I think I delay
that but this latest trend with the 90s
in the all the athletic clothes and the
boxy things and the block the clothes
block colors and horizontal stripes and
all this I'm not on board for this one
you know and I feel like I'm kind of
taking an exit a little bit like I'm in
on I've been on this interstate for a
while that's sort of like okay I'm kind
of kind of kind of conscious of fashion
trends and I try to do something that
seems fashionable and I kind of dressed
like a young person but I've kind of
feel like I'm on the exit and I'm like
I'm 42 I think I'm gonna have my own
style and I'm not gonna be too worried
about what the general style is anymore
and I'm just gonna wear what I feel good
in I know the way the decision I've made
is more of I'm gonna get on a parallel
highway that still is moving I like I
like trying new things but I don't want
to emulate I don't want to start looking
like my son I mean a lot of shirts are
getting a little too small for me I end
up giving him the Lincoln he likes it
but he likes maybe a third of them he'll
wear some of them but yeah that's that's
that's waning it's just a different
aesthetic
but I I like to have fun with anesthetic
but I just want it to be my own thing
it's not just exiting and like parking
it's like well I'm just gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna I'm gonna go full dad I agree
with that
hop out the gap well that's what I don't
want to do because what you got you got
somebody like I don't go on Facebook
anymore but in the same way like
personally going on and like looking at
old friends photos and stuff like that
but I remember a decade ago when I did
the such a thing you go on there and
you'd so you know a decade ago I'm just
over 30 years old and you go on there
and you see somebody with the high
school with and you're like man that
dude has just but he's old it isn't oh
he aged it might be that with somebody
who's like lost hair their hair turned
gray or something like that but but it's
a lot a lot of is conformity they made
an aesthetic decision to be like I this
is my job I'm a professional and so I'm
going to dress and behave the same way
that everyone else at this place of work
does up to age 65 70 years old right and
so it's just like you see this 30 year
old person you're like man you don't
seem youthful anymore you seem old
because you've conformed you you've
instead of there being a slow
progression you just said I got to get
under this Lane I got to get into
professional Lane so now got my polo
tucked into my khakis right right but we
are in the art lane if you want to go
and so that's one of the things I love
about you know where I'm at my life is
that especially in this town where
there's there's no judgement for anybody
being anything they want to be in
expressing themselves because they're so
is some so much of an art nobody look
nobody looks at you funny well if you
dress weird so it's not that I want to I
want to stay relevant to the kids it's
that I want to be able to express myself
and say you know I don't want to conform
I don't want to conform to them because
that's kind of sad it's like okay you're
in your 40s you're trying to this is how
you're trying to connect with your 16
and 14 year old
looking like us at any moment you could
crash their party get well get into some
sort of ass-like an are ambiguous
athletic event like maybe there's a
uniform under that tracksuit right yeah
it ain't gonna work for us
but fine track suits are classic though
I will say that is something they'll
think we can do track suits it's
something yeah you could do that you
know I gave up on that you know I mean
you took that you wore that track suit
on GMM they call it really it really
caused a ruckus I can't even wear it the
whole episode can't even well but I
taught them but I didn't relate it back
to what we're talking we're late it and
let's shut this down cuz that would be a
dope way to end oh okay yeah I think
you've got to use it in mixed company
before it really counts so that was a
nice try to relate it back to this and
the question that you asked which is
like what are we out of touch you
haven't picked your word by the way
what's your word what word do you
actually think you can use fax that
could be tough to come up that's a tough
one because it's so definitive it
it's a closing statement like when you
say fax whoever you're talking to has
nothing to say it's like oh he just have
fax if you're like you fax is the end of
a thought but dope Candace no sir Nestle
it was it's a response though somebody
says the fax fax you know what I could
say I could do low key or high key
that'd be weird
yes but I think that's a good idea are
we backtracking on what we just said
that like our weed that's low key we got
to try it okay I know that this is
inconsistent what I just said about
getting on my own lane and like being an
artist and expressing myself like dope
is really easy I legitimately like
hip-hop okay I don't lie to get someone
like me they don't judge me Liddy's a
good time
I love the rhythms Thanks thanks man all
right I'm a I'm a beep waiting with
bated breath for that one but to relate
what I was just saying about the fashion
back to this is I do think that
I'm in with the fashion thing I've
there's been a little bit more effort
right and I and I do think that some of
it is the fact that we're free to dress
how we want to we don't know where no
one's gonna fire us for dressing a
certain way and there's no dress code is
there a dress code I mean never Kalia
probably has a dress code here like you
can't like you can't wear a thong and
nothing else
it's mythical entertainment and if and
if we haven't specified that yet we
should probably put that in the employee
handbook Wow
but you can dress how you want and we've
taken full advantage of that right well
worn a thong yet
thanks but with terminology lingo we've
pretty much continued to talk the same
way now we've lost our accent that we
had in North Carolina for the most part
comes back at certain times but that's
really a function of hearing yourself
hours and hours of your own voice heard
back you end up that happens with a lot
of people your voice ins and you end up
kind of change what are you getting at
I'm just saying that I'd feel absolutely
no compulsion to try to use any of this
but but we just came up with a
compulsion that you were gonna do it
yeah we're gonna die because it's fun
we're gonna do it because it's fun and
and and and hey maybe we'll learn
something we'll let you know but you let
us know
hashtag ear biscuits if you disagree
just go feel free to put us on blast as
they say that's good Rick Baby Rick baby
one two three four baby Rick baby one
two you know what i'm gonna do i'm gonna
make a recommendation for y'all all
right
i'm actually recommending this to you
because i think you'll like it i went
into a bookstore because I was told that
loss causes a bleak Creek had a placard
at the at Romans book store in Pasadena
so I went over there and they didn't
have it this is this is a over a month
ago now and I was in there I was like
you know what
I'm in a freaking bookstore I'm I it's
so sad but I booked maybe I should buy a
book cuz I was just thinking I'm just
gonna look around all these books but I
never thought I'd actually buy one
because I didn't think I'd actually read
one because I gotten out of the habit
but I picked up a book and I will
recommend it because I'm really enjoying
it
the reason why I was at somebody I went
to the sci-fi section I was like I want
a good sci-fi book got a book called the
three-body problem and honestly one of
the reasons that I got it was because it
won an award won the Hugo Award for Best
novel in 2015 it's part of a trilogy of
novels so if I really like it then I can
kind of dig in because I really like to
dig into a world if I like it that's why
once I started reading Game of Thrones I
read all of them it's originally written
in Chinese and and translated into
English which concerned me but it has no
impact and then what sealed the deal
isn't counteracted that made me buy it
not only did it have a cool cover but it
Barack Obama endorsed it wildly
imaginative hmm indoors whoo
endorsements really how did you get how
do you get Barack Obama to endorse your
sci-fi novel he's a sci-fi fan wildly
imaginative that's what he said I was
like man and I gotta get this the
three-body problem is a hard science
fiction novel hard science fiction yeah
I'm going hard is the first novel of the
remembrance of Earth's past trilogy by
writer Lou sixin that's all I'm gonna
say if you're if you're into oh man this
thing's it's done not very long either
right it's 327 pages that what I said a
lot of times sci-fi is so long that my
attention span is like not great I'm
halfway through like so many books right
302 page oh that's yeah that's great
so I'm halfway through it's it's
it's a fun wallet modern ative book yeah
it's got VR body problem you'll like it
because there's probably was a cashier
title in Chinese it the three-body
problem actually references a problem in
physics in orbital mechanics according
to the wikipedia so there's a lot of
physics involved a lot of smart
scientists are like the key the key
people in and say but it but it's also
like entered like being ready for
interdimensional battle and I'm only
halfway through the book so I could
spoil some things there's some things
I'm still like me is there something
alien going on here actually I don't
fully know yet
but there's a lot of VR there's an
amazing VR game within the book that the
way that that world works sounds like
it's laps is it's laps it's dope
that's my wreck I'll check it out yeah
check it out hashtag ear biscuits will
speak at you next week speak at us that
way to watch more ear biscuits click on
the playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]